- The CIFAR winter school
really allowed me to see
how different and rich
the approaches could be,
even to the same problem on
which I, myself, specialize.
- There are so many people from
very different backgrounds,
diverse backgrounds, different
stages of their career,
and all open-minded and willing
to discuss and dialogue.
- Now I can talk to people
from different fields
about different things,
and that basically gave
me a broader perspective
of what science is.
- For those of you that are really looking
for a unique opportunity to both
build a sense of community in research,
but also strengthen
interdisciplinary connections,
I would encourage you to apply now.
(upbeat music)